- I think I'm a human being who has ideas,
hypothesis and opinions.
Ideas, hypotheses and opinions.
And passion.
I'm IHOP.
I'm just IHOP.
I have ideas, hypotheses,
opinions and passion.
I'm the new fucking IHOP.
(upbeat music)
- [Voice Over] You got your perspective.
- [Gary Voiceover] I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Hey, everybody.
This is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is another
episode of Tea With Gary V.
Super excited.
I am here on this beautiful,
what is it Wednesday
Thursday morning.
I hope everybody super well.
Looking forward to the questions
just that I don't see any
questions in the queue
but I'll be ready for that in a second.
Nonetheless, hope everybody's super well
hope everybody's hanging in
obviously it's a challenging
time for a lot of people.
And so hopefully we can give some Q&A here
that brings some value to people.
My friend, A-Town, called me this morning
told me this show is not good enough
and it's not entertaining enough.
So I'm going to try to give
better answers than ever.
So let's rock and roll.
A-Town, I'm just kidding, I love you, bro.
Lucas.
Lucas, what's good?
- What's going on Gary, how are you?
- I'm, well, what can I help you with?
- Thanks for taking the
time out of your day.
I really appreciate this.
- Happy to do it, man.
- So just to give you a
little bit of context,
I'm a photographer.
I have a YouTube channel
where I document my process
more on the side of film photography.
So, essentially, the main
premise of the channel
is based around one show
called Value Shooters.
I go to the thrift store.
I picked up a 35 millimeter
camera like that's undervalued
and I shoot with it, review
it and then I give it away to
a member of the community
after it's all done.
- I love that concept.
- Thank you.
It's honestly, it's inspired
from everything that you do
that hence the name Value Shooters.
- I love it.
- And it kind of coincides
with Value Village,
which is kind of cool.
But while I'm there, I'm
also grabbing stuff to
flip on eBay, which is another cool thing
because like, now that
everyone's staying inside
eBay stuff is flying off the shelves.
But my question is,
is it too early for the ask?
Like I'm pretty early in the process?
I'm super patient.
I'm not in a rush at all.
Not trying to look at
like subs or anything.
- So then the answer is yes.
If that's your mentality, right?
Then the longer you hold
out the ask, the better.
- Gotcha.
- So a lot of people can't
hold out for the ask, right?
Yesterday we had some
people on TV with Gary V who
the musicians are so in trouble
and I told her to flip it and do donations
because they had to go for ask right away,
It's funny,
you picking up stuff from
those places to flip on eBay
is almost paying for your
ability to not go in for the ask
no different than my
public speaking allows me
to not have to go in
the ask for my audience.
And I think that's a really great model.
I think one of the things that
makes me stand out from a lot
of people is I'm not trying like as
how long have you been following me?
- Just over a year maybe.
- Right, so that first day you find me,
much like other characters
on the internet,
all sorts, you're like,
"Hey, when's the shoe gonna drop?
"When is he gonna ask me for something?"
I get that email all the time, like,
waiting for the shoe to drop
waiting for the shoe to drop,
but I don't need to and that's
what builds a real brand.
And I think it's okay
to go in for the ask.
I think it's very okay if
you want to sell something
or do something.
When I wanna sell empathy,
when I wanna sell case
with some pumped with that,
it's always okay.
I think the longer you can hold
off by not asking the better
- I see.
'Cause I'm not really a big
on like Patreon or anything.
I wanna still provide value with the ask.
- I agree, bro.
Empathy is a 45-dollar wine.
- Yeah.
- I feel thrilled buying
that for 20 bucks.
If somebody buys a pair K-Swiss,
they're gonna buy another
pair of sneakers anyway.
It's not like I'm making
them spend something, right?
And on the marketing
stuff it's free for life.
So I think you've got the
right mindset brother.
Keep going holding your breath,
bringing the most value possibly you can
to your audience without
asking for their money
is the greatest leverage point.
If you can subsidize
through flipping on eBay
and YouTube ads for the rest of your life
and never have to ask them
for something, amazing,
or if you ask them for something,
it's something high value like access
Like a weekend with you,
shooting in the woods for a week
and it's an experience it's $5,000 a head.
You can almost go super
premium once you build a brand.
So that's how I'm thinking.
- Yeah, I'm not getting any money on ads.
I'm still patient with that.
- It's early.
It's early, you don't have enough use yet.
- I picked up a job to kind of...
So I'm doing that full time,
almost 40 hours a week.
I'm living at my parents,
so I just finished college.
- Where do you live?
- Just like an hour outside of Toronto.
- Understood, fantastic.
- So it's just about the patience now.
- I like the peace.
I like the ingredients, you got it.
Are you doing TikTok?
- Yes, sir.
- How many a day?
Don't lie because we'll fucking
look and we'll call you.
- No, honestly, I was doing a lot.
I hit one that got pretty big.
And then I got lazy.
Because I'm like,
Oh, now I got--
- What you got your nut off?
You think you're somebody now?
- Not really but now I'm trying to put
one a day at least
but it's not pertaining
to what I do on YouTube.
So I'm trying to wait it.
Exactly.
- Pertain to what you're doing
that you're passionate about.
- Okay.
- When you do four a day you can do two
that are pertaining to
fucking camera lights.
And you can do one to flip life.
And you can do one to
having fucking epic hair.
- Yeah, thanks.
Do you think I should do flip life stuff
like on the photography channel too?
Because I don't wanna
bombard people with content
that they don't really care about
- I think you should try it.
I think you should try it.
Just to be like, "Oh,
fuck, I love that too."
When I do garage saleing,
when I do marketing,
when I do wine,
are there a group of people like,
"I don't want to hear about wine.
"I'm here to get fucking
tips to build my business."
I'm like, "Sorry, dude,
"but the next post is gonna be fire."
So people are crippled by one
piece of content, I'm not.
- I agree.
I don't feel that way either.
Because I post a bunch of shit
that I do on a regular basis.
Like when I go
(speaking over each other)
- Yes,
- I do a bunch of shit.
And they all do as well
as the photo stuff,
but I don't wanna care about that.
- You shouldn't because
what ends up happening is
it's building a depth with
a certain group of people
with you and that's great.
So I think you're good man.
Keep it going.
I appreciate you with this.
- Thanks man, lots of love.
- Stay well man, talk to you soon.
- Appreciate it, take care.
- All right.
Big shout out actually,
before we go move on.
Big, big big shout out to Jack
Catt with two Ts on Twitter.
I didn't even have to remind him to
share the Ask Gary V Show on Twitter.
As a matter of fact, I just
follow you, Jack in Bristol,
England and retweeted your share.
Please take a screenshot of this right now
and share it on your platforms.
It's got a ton of people to watch today.
I'm following on Twitter.
Not enough for you tweeting me right now.
So I need that.
Oh, big shout out to Jeff
Jake, Jase Dean as well.
Perla Rivera and retweeting both of you.
I love this reach with
republic of stellaris
I'm returning all of you guys.
I want you guys to get
tons of Twitter followers
And there she is.
Maria, what is good.
- Hi, Gary, how are you?
- I'm really well, how are you?
- Good.
I'm also from New Jersey.
So--
- What part?
- Tom Jiver right now,
- Love it.
- Yep.
- If it wasn't for you,
I wouldn't even be here asking
this question right now.
I'm part of the wrestling community.
I know you're like wrestling too.
I started a podcast with a friend.
And I love it more than...
I didn't know I was gonna
love it more than I could.
Exactly.
More than my job more than anything.
I love it.
I look forward to doing it all the time.
My question to you is,
I have a decent following
in the wrestling
community on Twitter only.
How do I get it out there to more people?
- More on Twitter or
more just in the world
- In general, like, I don't know.
- First you use your Twitter
to start building up your other platforms
you have to get on TikTok and
Instagram yesterday heavy.
- TikTok too?
- Right.
I would argue that TikTok
is your biggest opportunity.
For people that don't have big audiences.
In the macro, the biggest
opportunity is to be a first mover
in an emerging platform.
And TikTok is still emerging
even at its enormous scale.
Yeah, I mean, I think you
should do too wrestling.
Just like you're right
now, talk about wrestling,
what is not and then just learn TikTok.
Go to TikTok today and
spend an hour or two,
just consuming TikTok to
get a feel for the room,
and then start making the next day.
Yeah, two TikToks a day,
and then use Twitter.
Because Twitter is amazing.
You can tweet 30 times a
day and get away with it.
So use Twitter to build up
your TikTok and your Instagram.
I would probably put four to
five tweets a day per platform.
So that's 10 tweets a day,
pushing to your Instagram
and your TikToks.
They can siphon some
of your audience there.
And then you just start
building within those worlds.
That's the way you migrate audience
that gives you a little spark by using...
Twitter is the best platform
to have most of your users be
because you can use it to
push to the other places
whereas on Instagram you
can post 15 times a day.
You can use stories but
you need to get very serious
about those two platforms.
It will work.
- Twitter and TikTok
- Instagram and TikTok using
Twitter to build up there.
On Twitter, are you jumping in
to random wrestling conversations
and adding your two cents?
Good.
- Yeah.
- All day long more more, more more.
Like literally just you know, search and
- I do.
- Big John Studd, Ray Mysterio.
Just search and jump in, jump in jump in
- And I'll ask questions,
and I'll get a lot of responses
- Not that, not that.
Asking question is your community.
I want more people discover you.
So I want you to go on Twitter.
Right and I'll show you
actually this is fun.
Now they have time so I'm
going to Twitter right now.
And I'm literally going
to type in ECW, right?
Wrestling right?
And when I type that,
some things come up, I
hit, I like to hit latest
at the top latest.
So you hit latest on ECW.
And what you see is, 34
minutes ago somebody says,
"In the last 24 hours,
I've watched AEW Dynamite
"the rise and fall of
the ECW click from NXT
"and the rest of this episode."
What do you know this is?
And I can just reply, and I just replied,
I literally am replying to
this person right now lit.
- That you don't know at all.
- That I don't know,
Twitter is the cocktail
party of the internet.
- Well, here's my problem with Twitter,
because doing that, and I
follow you for two years,
and I shouldn't feel that way
and it takes a lot for me,
but the amount of haters
that you get well,
- Fuck that.
- I know
- Haters are the reason people
didn't like high school.
Haters are the reason
people don't like life.
Other people's opinions
are dogshit, fuck them.
This is like old school grammar shit.
If you jump into that
conversation, and they're like,
let's go to the most 16 Shut up, bitch.
You just move on what?
You're worried that
fucking big Johnston 49
called you a bitch, who gives a fuck?
He's a fucking loser.
If you would do that.
Feel bad for him.
Don't feel bad for yourself.
Maria, this is the number
one fucking mental thing.
Twitter is the cocktail
party of the internet.
You should be jumping into 50
to 500 wrestling conversations
a day on Twitter because
you're knowledgeable.
And when somebody says
something about Repo Man,
you bring up something about demolition.
- Okay,
- That was me showing my
nerd wrestling knowledge.
- It's old school but okay,
- Yeah, I am a little bit old school.
But but nonetheless.
Got it?
- Got it.
- Instagram, TikTok.
I need to see four posts from you today
on those two platforms.
And I need to see you jumping
into 50 conversations about AEW,
about Triple H, about missing China
missing about whatever
the heck is on your mind
jump, search,
search in there and get in there.
search, rock Wagner, the name
and then people are talking
jump in there right.
- Got it.
- Search Randy Warren and jump in there
and add your two cents search Gronkowski
and add your two cents
that you think he's a Doof
because he's a fucking patriot.
I fucking hate him.
He's entertaining.
I'm glad he's retired.
But do you know what I mean?
Add your two cents and if somebody says
You don't know anything and this and that,
drop knowledge on them.
I'll say good luck, Maria.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Big shout out to my
dad's business WineText.
Actually, actually team
I know you've been
asking about lower thirds
like I don't mind
putting WineText on here.
It is exploding WineText.com
if you're not part of it,
and you buy wine.
Get on it.
And plus now everybody's buying the wine
and the internet wine text.com.
Sign up.
Would mean the world to me,
because it would support my dad
Sean, your hair looks good.
Don't worry, bor, let's rock and roll.
- How're you doing, man?
- Hey bro.
- Thank you so much for having me on, man.
I really appreciate it.
- Happy to have you, brother.
Where you from?
- Man, I don't know if you remember
you sent me an email back in January.
I sent you an email about
some stuff I had going on.
You sent me this whole thing.
And you said, "You're gonna win."
And I was like,
"That's been my whole
motto for this year, man."
So I really appreciate it man.
- I do remember,
it's funny back to the joke I made
to start to show my buddy, A-Town's like,
"Hey, you need to do more."
And I'm like, "Bro, I do so
many things behind the scenes.
"Me and Lou send a mass to
hospitals around the country.
"I'm one on one replying to
people at midnight on my text."
2129315731.
I wanna remind everybody
that so many of us
are doing so many things
behind the scenes as well.
So like rock and roll
so just like that back in January.
Just sending that so I appreciate it.
Tell me, my friend, what can I help with?
- So you talked about yesterday,
I was watching yesterday
and if you weren't watching
it today you missed out.
So my question is just further into,
what can musicians do to
be successful at this time,
like you talked about
doing the live streams
and throwing up the link to
the Vimeo and stuff like that.
But I guess some of the
concern I've heard from
other artists and stuff is
like the wells gonna run dry
after a certain amount of time
and my argument is after
watching you for four years,
that if you provide good content,
the cream is gonna rise to the top.
- It's true.
- So is there anything you feel like
I can do to try to differentiate myself,
I guess from everything
else that's going on?
- Of course, being your honest self.
I think the biggest
differentiator is actually
more authenticity and more transparency.
There is only one Sean Marlon.
Your insecurities, sharing
that with the audience.
Only you can do that, right?
The way your voice sounds,
only you can do that.
The way you play it, only you can do that.
I pretty much suck at everything
besides being fully Gary Vaynerchuk
and that means I garage
sale which confuses people
and that means that I stay
private with the things that
I'm most proud of when I help and donate
and things that nature
and it means that I prefer
to do one on ones like this instead of
Jay being with other famous be
like I'm just best that means
I'm we're talking about sports cards,
and I'm willing to hustle 15 hours a day
and I'm willing to talk about the Jets
and hate patriot bands.
100% no matter what and--
- Making that guy take
the helmet down yesterday.
- That's right
and love my family and
support me in sports
and AJ, I'm me.
I'm me in a world where I watch
people trying to be
anybody besides themselves.
I'm gonna be like,
"Oh, I love what that person did,
I'm gonna be more like them.
I don't fucking wanna
do what anybody's doing.
I don't give a fuck about them.
- Just you know that out.
- You know how to break out?
you know how to be different
by being different.
Everybody else just trying
to be like somebody else.
I'm trying to be Gary fucking Vaynerchuk
- You're on it.
It's just, it's overwhelming, man.
Just watching you for four years.
Man, I've gone through
some tough stuff, man.
And it's just, like all
the different quotes
that you have and I've
posted stuff up in the room.
Different quotes that you
have just to motivate me
to keep going like when I have a bad day,
especially now after getting that email.
Like the first thing you
said is, "You're gonna win."
And every time things
get a little bit down.
I'm like, "I'm gonna win, man.
"Gary said I'm gonna win.
"I'm gonna get this.
"I gotta keep driving."
- Yes, you're yes,
I do know and you're so young, dude.
How old are you?
- I'm 33 next I'll be 34
- Bro, do you know what, 34 is when I left
to start Vayner media?
- I know, man, I think about that a lot.
I'm like, Man, this could be the time.
- And by the way, and maybe
for you the time is 46
and guess what?
You'll still have 50 fucking more years
to live up to 46 we need to
change this age is a mindset.
We do not have a good relationship
with time in the world.
Everyone thinks it's all running out.
33 is a fucking baby.
I texted a bunch of people on
my text platform last night
that were like 68 to 72 and I
just sent a message of like,
we got 30 more years of fucking damage
and it was funny the replies they sent me
but they get it.
Do you know what a 68
year old thinks about
how young you are?
They're like,
"Motherfucker I got shoes
holding this fucker."
- Yeah,
"Cause I look back at
ages I've done before
and I'm like,
"Man, if I'd realized how
much time I have then."
I'm like, Well,
I'm probably going to think
that later about this time,
so I should just go in there right now.
- That's right, I love
where your mind is man.
Keep pushing by the way.
I love you.
- I love you too, man
- Be you.
Make the content about you, your truth.
Those hard times, get that
poison out of your body,
because a lot of people will
associate with you on that.
- I appreciate it man.
- It'll be therapeutic for you,
and it will make a
connection point with others.
There's only one you bro.
That's the only way to break through.
- Appreciate it, man.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so much.
Everybody's watching hopa.
Awesome I'm sorry, getting some
of this getting some stuff.
I'm ready doesn't.
Let's see who's sharing.
There we go.
I see some sharing.
All right, Adam chime, Preston Alexander.
You're getting shared.
Let's go.
Put screenshots and links
to here we go Aleksei
For you like that,
Steven Stanwood, I agree.
That's a good quote.
Matthew H, whart's good, bro.
- Gary, how you doing my man?
- I'm doing well.
- Thank you so much
for taking the time doing this.
I feel inspired and
grateful for this for sure.
- Happy to do it.
- Thank you.
So I'm, an elementary education major
at the University of Iowa.
And at the December of 2018,
I started my podcast called,
be Kind, be positive, be
yourself just because 2018
was the first time I experienced
hard anxiety and fear
and depression and I
wanted to start right away
- Why?
- Break up with the girl.
I thought it was and I had never,
I had to figure myself out.
And everything and I wanted
it was more therapeutic
to start my podcast for myself.
Fast forward to now and
we built a community
and a lot of people and
a lot of connections
I never thought I would have.
And, you take all the time
and I look at you as a role model.
Because you use your platform, Empathy,
optimism positivity as
making it cool, right?
And you lead with it.
And I really respect you for that.
And that's what I'm trying to do.
So my question is people that
are in a pessimistic route,
or kind of down on the time's right?
How do I encourage them and
lead them with positivity
without coming off as rude?
Or overbearing or anything?
Just, Yeah.
- And this is an aggressive motion,
so I'll give it to you
a different way, like,
- Okay,
- Or.
Bro, it's just consistency.
Consistent conversation in perpetuity.
Bro, I've been doing this for a minute,
and I'm gonna do it when 107
and it's gonna be consistent,
and people are gonna leave comments
and whatever form comments are in 25 years
saying you say the same shit
and I'm proud of it, dick.
I'm proud of it dick, do you understand?
How do you do it by you staying consistent
by you having perspective.
And then how do you do it?
I find different ways to
keep saying the same thing.
Got it?
New adjectives.
My vocab has expanded
dramatically over the last decade.
Different analogies.
I'm great analogies.
My mom's dad was supposedly great analogy.
She always tells me I
picked that up from him.
I crushed analogies.
I love that shit.
Being fully myself when
I broke out in 2009
most of the world in the
comments on LinkedIn, Facebook,
Instagram, and on Instagram,
Twitter, Facebook and YouTube,
and definitely email and
definitely my friends.
My inner circle of business associates,
almost everybody told me to stop cursing
that I would never get big if I cursed.
- I remember that, yeah.
- 2009 this way before you do
2008, 7, 6 like early me 2009
Maybe you were there.
Nonetheless, I apologize.
Way back then in '09,
the culture was a little bit different
and cursing was a little bit more like,
but that's just the way I
taught my mom fucking curses.
That's why I picked it up.
I know you're watching mom take that.
She's cursed in Russian.
So it took me a while to
realize she was actually cursing
but I'm a jersey outside in the woods.
Kind of like jersey kid.
That's how we talk.
And so I was authentically
me, I've stayed consistent
and I'll always be consistent.
That's how you do it, Matthew.
- And do you think just
and I've always tried to tell
my podcast people like
I'm gonna be transparent.
I've shared the bad times as well
in the past year and a half.
And I think that I kind
of thought to myself
kind of what you're saying, if I'm right,
is that if I be myself,
maybe they'll come around after so much.
If I just be consistent.
They might be like,
"Oh, maybe I should try
this positivity thing."
Is that kind of
- Matt, do you understand that
some people have followed
me literally for six years
every day and today's the day they fucking
finally take my advice?
That's exactly the reason
you have to be consistent
is you never know when today's
the day that they're ready
and you say it the way that
they're ready for people like
people ask me all the time to like,
"Hey Gary, do you ever get
tired of people not listening?"
I'm like, "No, it's not about me."
I need to just be consistent
say it different ways
challenge myself creatively.
So that today's the day
and I say it the right way.
Boom like I didn't know
coronavirus was gonna come
that was going to give me an opportunity
two-hour morning show every day.
Somebody's gonna get
affected from yesterday.
Somebody's gonna sell a
ton of shit in their house
that's gonna buy them
those two extra months
that are gonna change
the course of their life
because of the Sell Stuff Saturday.
This Saturday Sell Stuff
Saturday, look at the hashtag.
I didn't know that that was gonna be day.
I came up with it on the
spot as you probably saw
if you watched yesterday.
So no, bro it's about staying consistent
knowing today might be the day that
Karen in Illinois was
ready to hear it finally.
- Okay
- Should I throw the shit
I talked about people
don't want to do Be patient for 15 years
save money don't buy dumb shit.
A lot of young people are
gonna try every other version
before they come back to me they like
because I'm entertaining and
come across cool to them,
but they actually don't wanna do my shit.
Do you how many
hypocritical Gary V fans are
who loved me but do nothing
that I talked about.
- Yeah, that's what I needed.
- Gotcha.
- Thank you.
(Both speaking)
- Let's keep this going.
This one, by the way.
I'm really enjoying
everybody's taking screenshots
of this and posting it on Twitter.
And I'm retweeting their accounts.
Cory Waters you're in
and I'm going to start
following some of you fuckers
moving Carrie Cory waters.
You've just been following Cory.
I see that you're in New Jersey.
I'm gonna ask you to now are
you signed up on WineText.com?
Of course you are.
Let's see what Corey responds with.
I like this.
I like the sharing there we go Matt Smith.
Hey, Jenna.
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm well how are you?
- Good, thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
I'm super grateful to
be on and super excited.
- Where are you from?
- From Long Island New York.
So not far.
Yeah, so, I've had a side
hustle for two years now.
It's a clothing brand.
I basically market to
people who are underpaid.
That's actually the name of the brand.
Yeah, and on even before
- I love that brand
- Thank you.
Even before all this
- Because by the way,
I apologize for interrupting you
why that's such a brilliant brand name.
Everybody thinks you're underpaid.
- Yeah, exactly and that's
why I came up with it.
But lately I've been thinking about
did I pick the right niche
Sales have just not been good
and I've been slowly
losing passion for it.
- Are you losing...
So listen let's talk
about passion real quick.
What do you have a sense
if your passion is money
karma that's A,
B, the process of making money.
Is it A, money actual money?
Is it B the process of making money?
Or is it C, having a fashion
brand and being creative?
Which one is your passion
and by the way, Jenna
This is an important moment like
all three are acceptable.
There's nothing wrong with any of them.
I'm just curious because
it's gonna help me help you.
- It's definitely C, like I want to,
- Well, then money.
You're losing passion because
you're not getting results.
Like you're in the best spot
because good news like you picked C,
So, if it's doing shitty right
now and it's a side hustle.
obviously you'd love it
to be your permanent job.
This now gets into we need
to think about the tactics
of you building a brand and doing sales,
not about the whole damn thing.
So that's a good start.
- Yeah, I did but I'm
also multi passionate.
I have a lot of things that I wanna do.
And sometimes it's hard to
pick what I wanna do and...
- You can do underpaid,
85% of time and 15% of the time,
do all the other random
shit because you're creative
and you're that kind of character.
And I find that doing
the 15% of other shit.
Empathy, Vayner Sports,
Gary V, Baseball Cards
actually makes me go 110% on the 85%
in running Vayner Media
because I'm also creative.
- Yes, see that's the thing,
I'm self aware enough to know that
I don't want to die like
whatever that side hustle is,
I wanna go all in on that thing.
And lately I've been thinking about
I've been drawing my whole life
so I've been considering
doing something with that
stuff or going like
more of like the artists Root.
- Let's stop for a second.
The answer is yes.
Draw Something post it on Instagram.
film yourself drawing it posted on TikTok.
People have the world confused.
The answer's yes to everything.
Like yes, go that route.
Everybody thinks it's like a thing.
Oh, I'm gonna make the
pivot now from fashion brand
and designer to draw.
They think it's like a thing.
Everybody thinks like school and life
like I go to school, then I go to college,
then I then I get a job.
It's not that
It's fucking flexible.
This is a flexible world.
The answer is yes, Jenna.
Draw some shit right now
and put it on the internet.
- I know it's like that simple,
but it's just like
- You know it's that simple.
There is no, it's just like,
I'm gonna pound this into your head.
Let's stick here.
The answer is yes.
I am a wine guy.
I am an entrepreneur.
I am a garage sailor.
I am a motivational
speaker to some though.
I'd like to consider
it practical optimism.
I am, I am, I am, I am, the answer's yes.
I'm a baseball card dealer.
Yeah, I'm a podcaster.
The answer is yes.
Everybody's a renaissance
woman and man now
you don't like it's not so structured.
It is that simple.
Draw something and post it.
- I just feel like when
I take on too much,
I'm spreading myself too thin and then
I just end up becoming like,
mediocre at a bunch of things.
And so tonight the common
and expert in one thing
- No, Nope.
It's an ideology that people use,
because they over judge themselves.
- Yeah, make sense.
- Treat yourself.
Like you've got like, I
wanna break you out of this.
It's about perspective.
All this is, all of this
is about half glass full
half glass empty.
Yesterday talking to my dad about an idea
for Wine Library around WineText.
And when I was done telling him about it,
he went right into the
things that could go wrong.
And I spent the first 18 minutes at it.
I spent the first four and a half minutes
explaining it to him on everything that
was gonna go right.
That's just two men with
two different perspectives.
- Yeah, I mean, like as
far as the brand, though,
you talk about staying in your
lane and only talking about
what you're an expert in.
I wanna get people value, but--
- Hold on like, I don't
I don't think say about
you know, it's funny.
This is why it's so fun to
have some time to break down.
I don't say stay in your lane
of what you're an expert in.
I say stay in your lane.
If you're passionate about
drawing that's your fucking lane.
Jenna.
- No, I know that like
as far as like my clothing brand
the reason I've been losing
passion as well is because
I put out content like
I have a YouTube channel
and I talk about being underpaid.
I talk about my story, but I
feel like there's only so much
I can only so much I
can talk about my story.
I want to help people who are underpaid.
- How many
- I'm not a career coach,
I'm not a finance expert.
- You know what you are?
You're a human.
You're a friend.
What am I?
I'm a human being.
You're a human.
- Yeah,
- You can be doing what
I'm doing right now.
How many people have bought
something you have a Shopify?
You control the direct to consumer?
- Yes, the Shopify store.
- How many people have bought clothes
Roughly,
- I fulfilled over 200 orders
in less than two years.
- Good for you,
- But sales have just like stopped.
- I got it.
That's not a lot and I get it.
- Yeah,
- You should email all 200 of them
and ask them if they'd like
to go on FaceTime with you
or live and talk about the whole concept
or what they liked about it.
Literally email them what's
gonna happen in a million say,
Unsubscribed, fuck you?
You can do it.
What I'm saying is whether
you do that or not,
you can do anything,
everything can be done.
You wanna help people you
want to talk to people.
You don't need to be a
certified psychologist.
Don't say you're a certified psychologist.
Don't lie, tell the truth and do.
You're a friend that wants to talk.
You're a human being that wants
to talk about this subject.
I don't think I'm an expert
in business, I don't.
I think I'm a human being
who has ideas, hypothesis
and opinions,
Ideas, hypotheses and
opinions and passion.
I'm IHOP..
I'm just IHOP.
I have ideas, hypotheses,
opinions and passion.
I'm the new fucking IHOP.
Do you understand?
That's what I think I am.
And I think you need to
think of it that way too.
- Yeah, I mean, I could do that.
I was actually thinking
about starting a podcast
and doing that, like talking
to people who are underpaid
so they could share their story.
- Jenna, Can I give you
a huge piece of advice?
- Yeah.
- Do you have a Twitter account?
- Yes.
- Were you just listening
to the wrestling woman
that I told to jump into conversations?
30 minutes ago, on Tea
20 minutes ago on the show.
Did you see that interaction
with the woman from Jersey
who does wrestling?
It's okay, if you didn't.
I'm just curious if you did.
- Yeah, I wasn't fully paying attention.
- No worries, I get it, I get it
So let me tell you where I'm at.
I need you to go into Twitter.
Search the term underpaid
and jump into a conversation
with every single person.
Read what they wrote.
And then say yeah, girl, or like,
Hey, have you thought about
this or this is something that's
but I want to remind everybody,
I Gary V was built on Twitter
by listening to people talking
by searching on Twitter.
You know how to search terms on Twitter?
- Yes,
- I want you to search underpaid.
And I want you to jump into
every conversation round people
talking about underpaid
for two hours today,
and then get back to me
and tell me what happened.
- I tried that a little bit.
- I don't give a shit.
- I think I tried to one.
- I don't give a fuck.
- Yeah.
- I tried selling a ton
of shit once and twice.
And third, and it didn't work.
I tried to invent a Deal
of the Day site for my dad
for a decade and I finally
figured it out with WineText.
I don't give a shit.
- That's crazy, yeah.
- Jenna--
- I haven't been on this.
I have been listening to what
you've been saying with like
sending Dms.
I've been sending DMs to
some of my favorite rappers,
a couple of them I sent out to so
and that's something that like
I was fearing doing for so long.
It's so crazy how you
feel something I know.
- You're feeling a lot of things.
I've spent seven minutes with you
You're in know and fear culture,
and even the framework of if
I don't focus on one thing
it won't work well is actually just a
manifestation of fear and insecurity.
- Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, that's gentle.
- Jenna, Listen to me, listen to me.
Life is good.
You could do this.
You're a creative woman.
Let's go fucking do this.
Just fucking one year closure.
Do me a favor, do old Gary V a favor.
For one year.
Just close your ears, don't hear anything.
All the negative feedback,
all the pushback,
all the bad sales results.
Just make make, make, make, make make.
I don't want to hear
from any of you anymore.
Like I've been thinking
about doing a podcast
fucking do a podcast?
I don't want to hear from
anybody anymore saying Yeah,
I heard you talking about
TikTok, I'm debating it.
Fuck debating, fuck thinking,
fuck pondering, fucking make
Go, make.
- Yeah I need to get into
that the mental hurdles
the hurry thing just dealing in and
- It's called this,
it's called stop listening
to other fucking people.
Your mom, your dad, your
uncle your brother your sister
anonymous pants 47 like
everybody, stop listening to them.
- Yeah, that's true.
I've been thinking about,
did I lose the passion
because the sales stopped
or did I lose the passion because
I wanted to do other things, but I mean--
- Are you ready for this.
I believe that if you do
all these other things
20% of the time you're
gonna find your passion
back to the brand.
Or stumble on
Stumble on the thing that you
actually were meant to be,
which is a drawer.
- Yeah, like that's my passion.
That's why--
- Can you do me a favor,
listen, listen me.
I'm actually giving you
tactical prescription
a tactical prescription.
I want you to reply to 50
people on Twitter 50 today,
I see that would take me an hour,
it might take you five hours
because you're out of practice,
or you've only done it one time.
I need you to spend.
I want you to find 50 people who have
put in the word you know underpaid,
then, and I'm not kidding.
You have an Instagram?
- Yes.
- I'm going to say something very weird
and I want you to do it.
I want you to draw something
post it on Instagram
and literally say sorry guys,
but Gary V made me do this
because that's going to be the shield
that will let you do this.
I'm selling the strong for 80 bucks.
See what happens.
I mean it Jenna, Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Update me on what happened. Okay,
Back to my phone
Twitter, gonna retweet some
more people doing screen time.
Health pageant you like that?
That was fucking funny, let's do that.
Why would a PR I love that?
We go, I was showing you and Nicole.
Hi.
- Gary V, what's good?
- What's good bro?
Nico?
- Nicole.
That's without me.
- Nicole, I love it.
- Yeah.
- Good to see you today.
- How are you today?
- So well,
- I'm so so pumped to talk to you.
First off, I just wanna say
I'm super grateful for you
in my life because like I've
been grinding through your
content eight months through.
I knew from before it was just that
these eight months have
like transformed me
and I got super pumped
and I'm so so grateful.
So thank you for that from
the bottom of my heart.
- Where are you from?
- I'm from India.
But I'm studying here in Canada.
And well, universities
just sort of a backup
so to come to my points,
I'd like two questions.
One, I wanna be a musician.
So I'm really passionate about music.
So I obviously heard
you talking about TikTok
and I started TikTok account.
I have over 200 videos at this point.
But, but it's not working
out for me in terms of
the audience watching
because I'm still like,
35 followers at this point.
So I'm not
- Because you're not good at it right now.
- Right.
- Which is good.
Okay, that's fine.
But what you need to
learn from this point,
you can't have 200 videos
and have 35 followers,
you needed to realize
somewhere along the line
that you have to do something
completely different,
because nobody likes what
the fuck you're doing.
- Right.
- And that's okay.
- Yeah,
- And you know, my mindset.
I think it's fucking awesome
that you have 200 videos
and only 35 followers
You might be the worst
TikToker in the world.
And I think that's amazing.
- Yeah, yeah,
- I think that's a good thing.
- Yeah,
- What I would do right
now, Nicole, is I would
your next five TikToks
You have to do something
completely uncomfortable,
completely different completely.
If you don't dance, you
do a ridiculous bad dance
with one of the trending dances,
you look at the trending hashtags,
and you come up with something,
instead of doing what you've...
What have you been
mainly putting up there?
- All singing videos.
So like, the other day there was this guy.
I'm pretty sure you watched him.
So it's about I'm bored in the house.
I'm in the house bored.
So I took the song and
I made a melody for it.
And then I posted on TikTok,
- I like that,
- And yeah.
And then like one person commented,
and she was like, "Oh, this
should be more popular."
But again, like it got a bit of traction,
and then it was like dead,
- Can I give you a few?
Okay, I'm gonna give you a recipe today.
I want you to go to TikTok
and I want you to leave a comment
on 100 100 different posts.
Got it?
- Yep.
- Watch, it and write a reply.
I believe that three of
your replies could go viral
and then that will double
your audience in one day.
Hit me up on Twitter tomorrow
and tell me what happened.
- Sure, will do.
- Okay, number two second question.
- And my second question was,
so I obviously got I watched
since I've watched a lot of
your content I got into like flipping,
and sports cars and stuff like that.
And honestly, I'm like a guy
who loves trying out stuff.
And like seeing it to me.
And like in so it's been like,
three months since I started
flipping and stuff like that.
I've been flipping stuff.
I am doing with sports cards.
And it's been pretty good.
But I feel like I'm just confused whether
that's my thing, because a
lot of my time goes into,
doing that because you're sourcing stuff
and then coming back.
Like an international student.
I don't have like a car or anything.
So I'm obviously commuting
costs and stuff like that.
And I'm still new to the city itself.
- What about buying stuff on the internet,
having it shipped to you
and then re flipping it so that you don't,
so you can maximize
your arbitrage of time?
- Like you mean like sourcing from Alibaba
and stuff like that.
- Yeah, or just sourcing
from the internet.
I mean, I buy cards on eBay,
have them delivered and
then repost them on eBay.
Because I was right that the
player was going to be better
than when I bought him.
- Yeah, I mean, I started doing that.
But like my question
was that I don't know if
I enjoy it as much as I like I do with
- I can tell you right now,
I already know that you don't.
- Right.
- I can just like you
should not be flipping.
I'm glad you gave it.
You're crushing it.
You know how I talked
about tasting things.
You're very good at it.
It comes natural to you.
News alert, just like 200 videos,
only get 35 followers
you need to change it up
three months and the level
your voice went down
when you started talking.
You don't like it as much right?
And remember what I
talked about fuck Gary V
fuck anybody else be you.
It's clearly not for you.
But I'm pumped that you tried it
because it might have
been the life changer.
We now need to move on to the next thing.
- I mean, honestly, I
was coming in for more.
- Or.
- Yeah.
- Or maybe you need to
flip something else.
Maybe flipping sports cards, not fun.
But going to thrift stores
and flipping fashion is fun
or maybe going Alibaba and buying,
a white mug for three
bucks and then selling it
for 11 bucks on on Etsy
is exciting for you.
So maybe it's what you're flipping,
- Right.
Sure.
I mean, I honestly got into flipping
and then I started looking
at from a money angle,
because I'm obviously like
your international student.
And my parents are paying for my tuition
and I always had them to
obviously give it back right.
- Yeah.
- And but in the process,
like you always talk about
pursuing happiness and passion
and that's gonna lead
you to earn more money.
Right and like,
- Not necessarily more money.
Happier money.
- Right!
Yeah, sorry.
- To me $112,000 a year
take home selling glasses
because that was what it ended up being
is much better than
$400,000 being an engineer
because that's what your
grandma wants you to do.
- 100% yep.
- I believe that.
I don't know what else to say.
I mean, I've lived life,
I'm old at this point.
It's very obvious to me.
Like, it's just very odd.
It's a fucking black and white.
And every fucking person
that tells me like,
"Fuck you," like, I'd rather
have to warn you like I'm like,
just because you don't know.
Because you don't.
Because you don't have $400,000,
that's what you think, motherfucker.
- True.
100% yeah, it's the process.
- So not more, not more.
And that's an important part.
And this I'm using tea with Gary V
to create more clarification,
because when people hear more
when they don't make more
after four years, like fucking Gary,
I'm like that you love
selling fucking pumpkins,
and like yeah I do.
You won.
- Yeah.
Right.
So yeah, I just got confused within that
because I'm like trying
to help my parents right
in the process of like--
- Real quick, Nicole,
you have your whole life
to pay your parents back.
- Yeah,
- You're not in the position right now
to really crush it.
Do you understand?
Patience, my man?
- Yeah.
Gotcha.
- Cool, I'm gonna run.
Talk to you soon, man.
- All right.
Thanks, man.
- Thank you.
All right back to Twitter.
By the way, here's something
I will follow every person
that tells me that they just signed up
for WineText on Twitter,
if you sign up to winetext.com right now,
not every state can be shipped to you
but if you do, and you tweet me right now,
and you say just sign I can
be just sign up for WineText
and show me the confirmation screen.
So shoot that because I'm
not fucking trusting you.
I will follow you on Twitter.
Hello.
- Hi.
- What's your name?
- Milonga.
- Milonga, how are you?
- Pretty good.
Thank you how are you?
- I'm well, what's going on?
- Well, my family and I run a restaurant
and it's been in our family for 63 years.
And I actually am
passionate with the business
and I'm really deeply connected to it.
And our brand is who we are,
which is that we love
people we love serving.
My family came from Yugoslavia.
And really, America
has been so good to us.
So now Coronavirus is here.
And we're doing carry out.
And we are known for being old school.
And so I've been using
technology, Instagram, Facebook.
I'm not that old, but it hasn't
come that naturally to me,
but I have started to do
more of it with sort of
your promptings and advice
and I wanna know in these,
let's say 18 months door to door
the Coronavirus sort of keeps us here,
what can I do to learn
from this help my business,
do things that I wouldn't normally do
because I wouldn't have the time
because we're so hands on and sort of
not intimidated by it.
- Is there any way that we can film,
whoever it is, whether it's you
whether it's another family
member, whether it's a chef,
is there any way that we can
film the Making of every dish
you sell from home or one
person goes to the restaurant?
Is there any way we can do that?
- Well, what's interesting is
we're known for all of our
recipes being family secret.
So the old role,
- Oh, that's cool.
- That's the only way.
Its the only way that you can get a recipe
is by providing a male heir to our throne.
Otherwise, we sort of don't share it.
- It's amazing.
So listen, people buy from people.
So where I was going with the recipe,
and now maybe we go a different route.
How many family members
are in the business?
So my mother, my brother
and I are there every day,
but I have two sisters,
and we're always there.
I mean, we'd run the restaurant.
It really is our home.
- I'll tell you the number
one thing that I would do.
I would try to put out on Instagram,
Facebook, YouTube, TikTok, all of them.
You have to sign up for all of them.
And I know you get it, and
you're on two of them now
and I get it's not natural.
I believe in this so much.
I think you need to do storytime.
I mean, your mom probably has
fucking some real crazy shit.
You guys have a ton of crazy shit
because you're like living
above the restaurant.
I think you need to put out 100 videos
of different stories about the restaurant
and post them locally.
I genuinely believe that it will lead
to an increase in takeout during now.
And it will be build even more brand.
Do you know how much good business things
and good life things happen to me
because people know I was born in Belarus
because they know I sold lemonade as a kid
because they know I sold baseball cards,
stories, the Bible, movies.
It's all about stories.
And I think while we're
all confined right now,
everybody needs to go
into hardcore storytime.
You have a real blessing.
You guys have real fucking stories.
I literally think you
take a fucking phone.
First of all, you'll be happy that you
recorded your mom telling 25 stories.
One day anyway, you know what I mean?
I think it's storytime for you.
I mean it, 100 stories
from the five of you,
from the six of you and
posted on every platform,
and you'll learn how to post
it differently on TikTok
than on YouTube.
Like, this is your time to learn.
- It is, don't mind learning.
- And good news.
You know what doesn't come
natural to me working from home
and here I am on the fourth
day, and I'm fucking liking it.
- Are you really?
- Yeah, I'm shocked.
So maybe you'll really like making TikToks
you just don't know until you do it.
Storytime.
Please do me a huge favor.
Today's been a big day on
Tea with Gary V about action.
Please record two stories today.
- I will.
- I love it.
Talk to you soon.
Get everybody involved.
It's one of those stories
from your mom will go viral.
I'm telling you right now it will
- Yeah, for screaming at me maybe
- Even better.
Talk to you soon.
- Thanks.
- Keep the this going and see.
I'm made a promise so
if you've just signed up
WinText site and being
so what's going on here?
There we go, I've been signed up Gary.
That's true here.
I'll also follow you for that
since you've been signed up.
And Tanner's in the building.
Tanner, what's good, bro?
- I'm doing well.
How are you, Gary?
- I am doing really well, man.
I really feel like there's
something here with this format.
- I totally agree.
I've watched every day and
it's definitely a value.
- What's your biggest observation so far?
- Honestly, with your Ask Gary V Show
it feels a little similar to that,
but you're going even deeper.
It doesn't feel as rushed.
So I think--
- Because I'm not rushed.
- Right,
- As much to your point.
- Yeah 100%
- And I think its right.
And table.
Yeah, it should.
Anyway, what's up my friend
- Yeah.
So I'll get right to it.
So I grew up, just telling my truth.
I grew up very well off.
My dad came from very little,
he worked on the family farm.
And then he started his
own client service business
was very successful.
And, so I grew up very comfortable.
My mom parented me,
perfectly, as you say, a lot,
I agree, with with how I was parented,
but he, unfortunately,
suddenly passed away at 45.
And I was 17 at the time.
- Oh, sorry, I'm so sorry.
- Yeah.
I appreciate it.
But basically from that moment forward,
I kind of went into a cocoon,
just full insular in my head
and I really didn't come
out till after college.
And so fast forward to
how this is relevant,
kind of what my question is.
I've been a freelance web designer
and developer for about five years now.
And the problem is I fully believe that
I self sabotage myself.
And I think it's connected
to what had happened.
My dad
- How do you self sabotage?
Because I actually think
you're about to hear a bomb.
I think I self sabotage myself too like,
I limit my financial upside.
Because I think for
me, I think I just love
the game so much and I almost
don't want to get there like
I'm appropriately in love with
the story and the process.
And kind of wanna pull
it out in the 12th round.
If I can buy the Jets the way I want.
It's almost like the Jets announcing three
they're gonna sell it.
I'm nowhere close and then
I fucking make it happen.
Why do you think when you
say you self sabotage?
And what do you mean and
why do you think you do it?
- Well, yeah,
so like how I do it is
basically through undercharging.
- Okay.
- Like drastically, and I don't know,
when I went into dealing with everything,
I really became 100% self reliant.
And I turned something into I turned that
terrible negative
situation into a positive.
I started weightlifting.
I got mentally very, very strong.
And--
- It's funny my Norman Skurnick
my friend Harmon Skurnik shook me in 2001.
We went to Italy on a
wine trip for business.
And one late night in Italy like 2 a.m.
He looked at me because he
knows how close I am to my dad.
And there he was talking about.
I'm trying to remember the story properly,
I think his dad had passed recently.
And he said,
"You don't really become a
man until your dad passes."
And I can't believe it's 20 years later,
I'm bringing me up at one sentence.
I think about it a lot.
I very much think of myself as a man.
But I do think about, I'm very grateful.
I'd like to only become a man when I'm 100
because that means my dad would be 120.
But I, understand what
you're saying about that.
Especially somebody who had
an incredibly great gifted situation.
So, that level of that comfort,
that person I was taking
care of shake gift goes away,
and you kind of go inside yourself.
So, but I still don't fully understand why
the undercharging is
connected to self reliance
or things of that nature.
I actually think some people
are just naturally scared
to ask for more money, like just literally
and the way to actually
break that is to literally
no different like kissing
a girl, riding a bike,
having sex for the first time, swimming.
It's literally just the action of asking
And in today's digital world
where you can just email them potentially,
and text them like, "Hey, I'm
3.50 an hour instead of 1.75"
I actually think this is a very easy.
I've helped a lot of
people break this ceiling.
I just forced them even one of my friends
literally typed it asking
for $100 more an hour
and at work then it kind
of changed his trajectory.
Something for you to consider.
- Yeah, I mean, I definitely think fear
is definitely a part of that.
But more so I would say.
I like things that are
hard I don't like it when
it's easy and I also I don't feel like
I'm not materialistic whatsoever I kind of
went in the complete opposite
direction after all that
- Like what is all this and all this ship
doesn't mean shit right?
like I get
- I tell myself I don't
need the extra money.
You know what I'm saying
So I don't know.
- Lets talk about something else.
Are we okay with that?
Because I'm okay with
self sabotaging myself.
- Yeah, I probably do
it to a point where I,
have trouble paying bills.
- Well, that's a fucking problem.
- It might be a little--
- Yeah, that's a problem.
- Yeah.
- So good news, here we are,
rewatch this over and over.
this will be posted you will.
Dustin Let's chop this
and email it to Tanner.
Ready.
- [Dustin] I got you.
- Okay, ready?
Tanner what's up?
It's Gary V.
Charge more money this time.
Cool.
That's gonna be a little
clip, save it on your phone.
And just literally ask
for more money every time.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what to say, bro.
It's actually that simple.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
And I gotta tell myself,
like, you can try it.
And if you think it's
going to be so terrible,
then we'll see how you feel.
You got to do it.
So, I don't know when
you had that call with
that kid the other day.
In the Electrician Business.
That really really, if he's watching this,
cherish those moments, man because
you may not have been forever.
- That was one of the few
moments in last 15 years
of being on the internet
that I actually almost cried.
- Yeah,
- That was that was a big one.
I agree.
Anyway, and I really wish
you well, brother honestly.
This is an easy one man.
Honestly it's an easy one.
It's a hard one, right?
It's like anything.
Again, swimming, I was scared shitless.
Kissing girls, scared.
But it is easy.
It was just jumping into the water.
It was just kissing the girl
and I think you just need
to charge more money.
- I appreciate you so much.
Thank you for everything.
Talk to you, sir.
- Take care.
- Lets keep it moving.
Keep it moving.
Seahorses signed up today.
Alejandro
- Hey, what's going on, Gary?
- Life is good, bro.
What's going on?
What can I answer for you?
- So my question, not to
give too much backstory
or anything like that, but
it's just more of like,
so I'm trying to stream a lot more,
because I found like,
obviously, I have a passion
for video games, right?
That's what I grew up doing.
So I love doing a lot.
And, but not so much more lately
because I've been consuming
a lot of your content.
So I've been doing other
things outside of my life to,
uplift myself become more positive,
be harder and better worker.
But what I wanted to know
is what's your viewpoint
on providing free content with value
when other people in the
same area like let's say,
play the same video game as me
are providing that same kind of content,
but in more depth
or they're able to provide a
little more value for free.
- You can only do what you can do.
- Just learn and dive in deeper.
- Yeah, it's like bogus
better at it than you like
what are you gonna do about it?
- Work harder?
- Yeah, by the way, maybe it's more about,
maybe he might be better
at showing the skill set,
but you might be more entertaining,
or you might be more
vulnerable and talk about shit.
Or you might talk about
goatee culture in a way that
he can't.
This is about making
it about you like look,
there's probably nothing I
talk about that there isn't
somebody who talks about
that specific thing
quote "better" but...
Oh the cat is in the mix.
What's the cat's name?
- Z
- Z?
- She was on my lap Yeah,
- Z woke up because, Z girl or boy?
Alejandro, I think we
lost you for a second.
I hope Z didn't like, hit the line.
Alejandro?
Girl got it.
So, Z knows the good
stuffs coming right now.
So like, honestly, it's
just about being you.
You're getting caught up.
That's somebody is better at it
- Very
- Yeah, can you hear me?
All right, doesn't take
them off, unfortunately.
But I'll give the answer anyway.
(Alejandro speaking indistinctly)
Dustin, look we can move on Dust.
Alejandro I'm sorry, but here's--
- [A man] Was a little
- [Dustin] That's
someone hold on a second.
- No worries.
Alejandro I'll finish my answer to you
and then we're gonna have
somebody else on here.
Somebody else being better at something
will always be the case in
every situation in perpetuity.
There are very few
people that are literally
actually the best in
the world at something.
And so oh, there you are.
You will never be the best
in the world in anything.
So getting comfortable with
that and still doing it
because you can still be the
17th Best of the 17,000 best,
but it's free.
So, you're in a great spot
Honestly dude, you're doing
what everybody else does.
Everybody else is just
watching everybody else.
Bro, when I tell you that
I don't know anything
that might be agencies
that compete with Vayner
the other business gurus.
I mean, people are always
like, Oh, Rick Thompson.
He like I don't know.
I mean, I've heard the name of course.
- Yeah,
- But I don't know what
anybody's fucking doing.
That's what makes me happy.
All right, let's move on
just because he's chopping.
Let's move it.
- Great hearing something
like that from you.
- Thank you, brother.
Dustin lets move it he's chopping.
- [Dustin] I got you.
So this next person is Elijah Kim.
I think you talked to him yesterday,
the guitars for Roddiie Rich.
- Ah, Elijah, what's good?
- Yo was good.
It's chopping.
- Hey, so I mainly wanted
to come on here and say
because I took your advice.
I know you had that one video
where you're talking about
like, hey, if things aren't working out,
like move back home if
you have that option
and kind of readjust
because I was working
like full time last year.
I was working for a cannabis company.
I don't even smoke
They're just like super unfulfilled
I'm I'm 26 now right
and that feeling only
got worse as I got older
and I feel like it's
because I was kind of working
against that perpetual clock,
and so I
- And you know,
how much I hate that fucking clock?
If I could fucking break everybody's clock
what they're supposed to
do at 25, 30, 40, 50, 60,
bro I hate that fucking clock like nobody
- Yeah, yeah and I don't
even know if it was
self imposed but I just
know that I was at home
in Claremont, which is a
super slow suburban area
and like Southern California
I'm just like chilling
on the floor of my parents house
I'm like thinking I,
because I basically dedicated my life to
trying to make something
happen with music right?
And so I'm putting everything I can into
making my guitar sound great.
All this stuff and I'm just
like praying super hard
and then like after six
months of being back home
I met my friend, his name's Keith,
and he hooked me up and let sudden
I'm on tour with Roddie Ricch.
And within the blink of
an eye, to other people,
they're kind of like, "Oh
my God, that's so crazy.
"I never need to do da da da".
And so it was just kind of crazy
basically to overnight to kind of have
some sort of something happen like music.
So I just want to say,
I'm following your advice.
- It just makes me so happy.
I don't know if you've been noticing
because I posted a bunch
of Roddie stuff on social
I'm just so about his sound
and fuck with him so heavy
and just hearing the story
but just think about how
the world actually works.
It's just so fucking fresh, you know?
- Yeah.
What's crazy is that I talked to Keifa
the day after the album came out.
So he's like. "Did you
listen to the album yet?"
I was like, "Not really."
He's like, "Go listen to the album."
So I listened to it.
We hit rehearsals,
and then the record went
number one of the box
I was number one while we
were rehearsing for tour.
So it's like it wasn't even
that big of a deal like
everything was sold out
but it's like the venue's
they could have been bigger
just because the dude--
- Exploded.
- He's like 11 weeks
at number one now are 11, 12
- Caught ammonia
- So it was just so crazy
that you just being on tour
and all of a sudden like
that record just like
caught fire we're just like
- Dude, listen,
when I talk a lot about this one sentence
doing the right thing is
always the right thing for you
the right thing at that
time was taking a step back
and getting into that place.
If you don't move in with your parents.
This never happens.
The end.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So currently, I'm here and there.
Everything's obviously gotten
canceled with Coronavirus
and everything like that
or at least postponed.
I'm kind of like floating around.
I'm staying at my
cousin's house right now.
- Do you have your guitar?
- Well, yeah, oh yeah.
- You need to live on Instagram Live
and TikTok Live and make TikToks all day.
- Yeah,
- Yeah.
You need to make four TikToks a day.
If I fucking could play
a guitar I'd be fucking
the biggest person in the
world, with TikTok right now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You need to make four TikToks a day.
- Yeah.
Do you have like
- Remember how uncool the advice of like
go home and moving your
parents of 26 sounded?
- Yeah, that was rough.
But you know, it worked.
- Exactly.
Go make for TikToks a day, it will work.
- Yeah.
Is it just like showcasing what you want.
- What I think you should
do is look at the trends,
both trending dances and trending topics
and then incorporate that with your guitar
into however you think about it.
- Yeah,
- Right.
So I'm gonna look right now
Give me an example.
So like for example,
right now, on TikTok this,
you to discover
and you kind of look
at what's there, right?
What's trending right now.
Cats of TikTok.
Is your cousin have a cat?
- Yeah.
No, but maybe I could find what
- Relax.
Like, play by play, right,
distance dance, right?
So distance dance is exploding.
Right now with the first scene on TikTok
distance dances blowing up.
Now let me give you the guitar behind it.
And just like fucking riff something.
Boom, that could be the one
that changes your career again,
because Beyonce might see it
because she's bored right now
looking at TikTok and boom, bro.
It's about making.
- Yeah.
- Online class trending, happy at home.
Right and happy at home trend.
Somebody the first one that's
trending is somebody playing
the fuckin piano tell
me how that's different
than playing the fucking guitar.
Fucking make shit, bro.
- That's a good point.
- Four TikToks a day, Elijah.
I booked you'd listen
to something once before
and already changed your life.
You do this one,
TikTok's made for music content, bro.
You're fucking sitting at home bored.
What do you jerk off all day?
Fucking make guitar shit.
- Awesome.
I'm gonna do that for sure.
- I believe you.
All right brother to talk to you soon.
- Thanks so much, Gary.
- You got it.
Tea with Gary V, hope
everybody's enjoying.
Heading into the second
hour excited about this.
I have all sorts of tea companies.
By the way, talking about like meta,
like have nothing but
tea companies dming me
and hitting me up on email,
offering sponsorship deals
to drink their tea on TV with Gary V.
Something that came up three days ago.
So like, it all can
happen and you're like,
oh, but you're Gary V
but yeah fucking grinded
for a decade to put myself
in that fuckin spot.
Hey, Michael.
- Hey Gary, what's up?
- What's good, bro?
- Nothing really.
So I got a couple of questions for you.
The first one.
Well, to give you a
little bit of background.
I just finished school.
It was an 1800 hour
course, become a mechanic.
Got straight As.
Best possible attendance I could have.
I need a career.
I'm 32.
I've been sober now for
just under four years,
April 3rd, four years.
Thank you,
- Proud of you bro.
I'm drinking that tea like now.
- On it's a bank.
I mean, I need a little bit more caffeine
this early in the morning.
I'm in Florida, I'm one hour behind you.
But the question is, is
for a very, very long time,
I suppressed myself
through drugs and alcohol.
I listened to the music that
other people listened to
because they said that was the music
I needed to be listening to.
I watched the things on TV
that other people were watching
because they said that was the
best show on so for so long.
I suppressed who I really
was, and I feel lost now.
Now that the cloud is gone
and the cobwebs have been cleared
I find myself sitting looking
around what should I be liking
Is it okay to like this
is it okay to
- Yes.
- Feel interested in this?
Bro, who's in charge right?
To your point,
you valued other people
more than yourself.
So who was in charge in high school
was whoever the coolest kid was
that you know who was in charge of girl
who was in charge this phony
like your whole life to your point
Up until 28, 29 was was about
somebody else being in charge.
Now that things are clear up the answer.
Is it okay is yes to everything.
Because you get to be
the judge and the jury.
Bro, 90% of my real business friends
made fun of me for
making garage sale videos
the first time I did
it a couple years ago.
- Right.
- The good news was
they weren't in charges
and I said, "Go fuck yourself."
- Right, right.
- The answer is of course,
if you're a nerd than be a nerd
because nerds are cool now,
if you love cooking good
if you love ballet for some weird reason,
mother,
- Right, right.
- Of course, the answer's yes.
Who you playing for besides yourself?
You were playing for
everybody else's affirmation.
You needed outside affirmation.
- Absolutely.
- And that's why you got fucked up.
But now, and what I talk
about is inside affirmation.
You just you.
That's why I was talking about
that Drago ship from Rocky
4 why that is so hard.
He's like, I'll say it again
because I love to reenact it.
At the end of that movie when he loses.
He's like motherfuckers I
fought for me I was in the ring.
I wasn't fighting Russia versus America.
This was for me, for fucking me.
And that's where you got to convert.
It's all you now.
No more mom, dad, uncle,
best friends and past
pretty girl that you're
like, no you only you
- And I have one more question.
So in the process of me
getting back to you know
where or where I'm at now,
I've had to I had to write down a lot of
some of my baggage and
cleared up a little bit,
some of the resentment
and really processes to
be able to let it go.
I'm a big thing was a list of fears.
And I realized that,
getting completely honest with
myself that one of my fears
was not only the fear of
failure but fear of success.
For years, I've set the bar extremely low.
So any expectation of anybody else
was just lost on me because,
hey, we know we can't do it.
So why even expect anything out of the way
there was no letdown I
was already a let down
You know what I'm saying?
So now that I know that
I can get good grades
and I can get straight As and got a job
that I've been working towards
and it's my first job
out of drug addiction
after a decade is makes
more than what my mom's made
and my mom's been at her
job for 30 plus years.
And so it's like, man,
I have the real opportunity
to fuck this up.
What if I'm not competent?
What if I go in there and
straight As don't mean shit
to practical application?
- Can I give you the answer?
- Sure, absolutely.
- What you're going down the path of
is where you've been,
and this is why we got to fight it.
What would happen then you
want a good fucking mechanic
and you move on?
- 1800 hours towards being
a not so good a mechanic.
- Who gives a fuck?
1800 hours ain't shit.
- Right
- Who gets to judge you?
You're worried about judgment, bro.
Like 1800 hours I don't give a damn.
People spend hours watching
Netflix during Corona.
1800 hours ain't shit.
And number two what
somebody's gonna be like,
Oh, I know what you're worried about.
They're like, "See fucking knew it.
"You had fucking good,
he was good for 18 months
"but he's once a loser always a loser."
You're worried about
other people's opinions.
- Absolutely.
- Fuck them bro.
- No, no,
- No, I really, no, no,
this isn't one of those I'm like,
like, it's let's let's
play for a second here.
Like what?
Like why?
Like you're gonna have
to understand rewiring,
I mean you let me rephrase
you understand better than 99%
of the people here you've spent
the last four years rewiring.
like I admire you so much
- Thank you
- Do you know how hard it
is to be in drug addiction
for a decade and actually get out.
Most don't.
- Right.
- There's nothing you'll ever accomplish
professionally that I'll admire more
than your ability to get out.
- It means a lot.
I appreciate that.
- You already won.
I actually mean it too, bro.
I don't like throwing admiration around.
I'm a little bit weird
that way, like, you know?
I admire you, man, you already won.
Who gives a fuck if
you're a shitty mechanic?
Seriously, then you'll fucking sell hats.
I don't know.
It's time that you fucking stop worrying
about other people's opinions.
I don't give a shit.
Listen, I don't know how long
you've been following my content.
Where'd you find my content?
- Probably about two and
a half, three years ago.
Had little bites about fuck expectation,
those kind of things that probably helped.
- That helped.
So listen, bro, I play the reverse game.
I don't give a fuck that
people think I'm a genius.
Or they think I'm the best
or I'm going to buy the Jets.
I can't hear them.
I'm asking you to cut
out the boos, the booing.
I cut out the cheering.
You know why?
Because as a kid I cut out the booing
I didn't give a fuck that Mr. Riddle
thought I was gonna be a loser.
I knew I wasn't going to be
right and more importantly,
if I was gonna be, Mr Riddle's a loser
and everybody's a loser,
I don't give a fuck.
Nobody's life has
anything to do with mine.
And that's that.
The reason you're in self
doubt or anxiety of like,
does school map to skills here?
Will I keep flourishing?
What if I get fired?
It's because you still actually then care
what somebody is gonna say about it.
And until you look, the way you
got off the fucking bullshit
chemicals you need to spend
every day reinforcing,
when I fuck up here, when
I quit, when I get fired,
and everybody's got something to say.
I don't care.
I'm gonna start a pizza shop.
I'm going to work in a pizza store.
I'm going to ride a bike.
I mean, it doesn't matter.
- Thank you.
I appreciate it.
It really means a lot to me, man, thanks.
- Do you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, no.
I mean,
I know a lot of things
are easier said than done.
For a long time, I had help from people.
So I didn't fall completely
under the surface.
And the reasons why I am still alive,
so I kind of feel like
I, not so much owe them
but like, hey--
- You do owe them.
You owe them by being happy.
Not by making money or being a mechanic
or being professionally successful.
- Right.
I just want to show them that they're...
- Happy.
- They didn't waste
their investment on me.
- Happy.
What do you think your mom
your aunt or your uncle,
your best friend whoever
who'd, give him a shout out.
Who are the core people?
- My mom, my fiance and my
brother, my older brother.
And that's about it.
- Let me promise you something unreal.
Unreal.
You paying them back
isn't in the form of you
holding a steady job.
It's you being a happy human being.
- And they say that.
- They mean it, dick.
- Right, I get it
- Stop fucking trying to convert some shit
into something it's not.
Bro, I promise you those who just are
fucking grateful you're alive.
They don't give a fuck if
you're making 110 a year.
- Right?
- Bro, just go be happy.
- Thanks, man.
I appreciate it.
You're the man.
Thanks.
- You are, Michael.
I'm really really impressed by you, man.
That's real hard battle.
I'm real impressed.
- Thank you.
I love man.
I love you, man.
Really, you're exactly what I need
when I need it all the time.
You're so consistent.
And again, I mean you really get me going
you get me going through
hard times a lot of the time
and I appreciate that that.
An outside influence that's not padding,
Just trying to tell me what I need to hear
you tell me what I have to hear
and then I greatly appreciate that.
- I appreciate, Michael, thank you bro.
- Yep.
- Take care.
- You too.
- Dakota what's good?
- Hey, hey how're you doing?
- Well,
I am well, what can I help you with?
- So I've been following
your content for about
two ish years.
And I really, really love
not only what you say
but how you say it.
It really resonates with
me because I'm all about,
leaning in and trying to figure out
how people are saying and what their
what the intent behind
what they're saying.
And so I really resonate
with what you say I say it.
So first of all,
love and so I wanna pick
your brain about something.
So you always talk
about loving the process
behind what you do.
So, yeah, so my question is,
in your experience, are there any elements
to the process that you
find difficult to love?
- No.
Nope.
- Right, I figured.
- Because that's not the process.
People just want the good
points of the process.
- Right, exactly, exactly.
- Brother, Dakota.
People don't love the
dirt the way I love it.
I fucking love adversity
and fucking toughness
and pain and underestimation.
I got chips and shoulders bro.
- You're Right.
- You understand?
Yeah, no, of course I
don't find it difficult.
You know why?
you believe in me?
You tell me what you
and Michael just told me
all that love and compassion admiration
fucking that's intoxicating
I love it.
Next person comes on
and says you fucking suck review
a buying shit motherfucker
you suck fuck you snake oil
salesmen buying the Jets.
I fucking love that more.
When I have a great meeting
where I'd love to sell
and I'm selling Vayner we
close a $2 million deal
and I'm in my fucking element, love.
When somebody comes in and says
the fucking roof is
leaking in Chattanooga.
We had a flood in LFC
or we have somebody with the
Coronavirus, love that too.
Even more more time general, the leader.
The process is both.
Everybody loved entrepreneurship
the last 10 years
until today.
- That's true.
Very true.
- Oh, everyone's like, "Wait a minute."
Wait a minute.
I shouldn't have left that job.
- Right, hindsight.
- Everybody loves shit on their terms.
- 100% Yeah.
So I guess the where that
question comes from is,
I'm, right now I'm studying music.
And sometimes there's parts
about it that I'm like--
- Of courser, of course.
Learn to love.
- Oh, yeah, exactly.
- And, you know what helps
learning to love, patience.
- Exactly yeah,
that's what I've been
trying to like you've been,
you've been one of like, the big,
voices on like social media, whatever
that I'm taking from,
patience, patience, patience.
And that has helped me so much because--
- Thank you bro, that makes me happy.
It helped me to like,
everything's old school was up
for me from fourth grade on.
He was a fucking pain,
punished four times a year.
It was all.
- Right.
And I just sometimes I just stick I take,
like your words that get in
there just so you know that.
I know, you know that
you're doing it right.
But for me, so you're hearing
from me, it's in there,
because I just turned
25 and I'm like, man--
And I got all this time
in the world to like--
- Dakota, the bad parts of the process
are the most important
parts of the process.
- Right exactly.
Totally
- Love it.
Love it.
- Love to talk.
- This is super fun man.
Talk.
I'm loving this
Just love this shit.
Devin Alexander, what's good?
Jeremiah let me get you
off mute in a second time.
Here we go with me today Mike.
How are you?
- I'm doing spectacular.
- Where are you from?
- I live in Boston right now.
- Where did you grow up?
- In upstate New York
Western New York, Geneseo.
- Love it.
Love it.
Your Bills fan?
- Absolutely.
I'm so excited for next year.
- You should be its the most optimistic
potential you've had ever.
- Yeah,
- I just think that Josh
Allen stinks though.
What's going on, what can I do for you?
- So, a couple of years ago,
I switched up my content strategy,
my personal strategy,
"cause I'm a musician
and I tried to do a bunch of things online
to get my music heard.
So I started making
videos about cowboy boots
and playing songs at the end of the videos
to sort of share the fact that I do music.
And it did really well.
I went from 80 subscribers to
now almost 8000 in two years
And it's growing really fast.
I have like brand deals.
I'm doing giveaways on my
YouTube like every month.
- Jeremiah besides YouTube,
where do you put out content
to drive outside of YouTube?
Where do you put out
content to drive awareness
to your YouTube?
- Twitter, Facebook, I
have a Facebook boot group
as well with 1500 members of Instagram.
I've been dabbling with TikTok
but I haven't quite hit it yet.
So I guess just spend more time there.
- How often are you posting on TikTok?
- I've only done like four
in the past few months.
- Bro, Jeremiah, do me a favor,
let the serendipity of
this moment force you
to make two a day.
- Will do, for sure.
- Your cowboy boots.
Such a good, dude, you're gonna win.
You're one TikTok, dude,
you're gonna love me
so much in seven weeks.
- I already love you.
I've, like I've been following since 2011.
- More.
Thank you, bro.
What can I answer for you?
- So with all of the
subscribers that I have,
I've been trying to increase
the sponsorships on my channel.
And you are always saying that influencers
don't know how to price themselves,
but you've never actually said
how influencers should price themselves.
So that's my question.
- So what I talked about there is
they don't know how to price themselves
because they guess yeah,
through their management or themselves.
So sometimes somebody wants $7,000.
So WineText, right,
you can tell them pretty
obsessed about it.
We're starting to do
an influencer campaign.
And some people want $3,000 to post
and we've got them kind
of with their engagement
and their numbers priced
at 500 bucks, right.
And how do we do that?
We look at what we could buy
on Instagrams ad product,
how much a CPM cost per
thousand impressions.
And if we know that we can pay
eight bucks the wine lovers,
well, then that's kind
of like how we see it.
And if then we're getting
20,000 impressions
we do eight times, 20,
for that person and you just do the math.
Other people want 100 bucks,
and we've got them maxed out at 4000.
So yeah, people like
the way you understand
if somebody is gonna do a
sponsorship on your channel,
there's the ability for
that same boot company
to run ads on pre roll
YouTube against people
that searched boots on
Google against any channel.
Now, your endorsement has a value.
So it's not just even math,
your cosine has real value.
But for you on your side,
that's not your problem.
You need to price as high as
possible and when they say no,
you're more than welcome
to lower the price
- Okay.
- Because your endorsement
is a kind of non tangible.
For example, I don't do brand deals.
I've done one thing in my career
where I was a partner with K-Swiss,
but I don't do brand deals,
but companies have come to me
and offered me real real money.
Like on my podcast,
hefty six figures just to be like,
Hey, everybody asked me or
hey everybody the podcast
is brought to you by
let me give you a company like it
but not it brought to you by Salesforce.
Salesforce, a great
solution for all businesses.
All right, let's get into it.
Jeremiah is here today, right?
Just to do that.
I've been offered mid six figures, right?
And I've said no,
because really, honestly,
if I'm going to do that,
a lot of my audience Gary's
never done that before.
That's a big cosign.
Let me look at it.
Why were they able to get him to do that?
And very honestly, if I'm gonna do that,
I want millions of dollars
to even consider it.
That's it, because but you
can't put a tangible value
on my cosign just based
on how many subscribers
or listeners or watchers
of this Tea with Gary V ad.
So that's always one of the gray sets.
- So is it an outreach game
because the cowboy boot industry
is just really traditional.
I'm sure they're not doing the pre roll.
- Yes.
Yeah, it is an outreach game.
You should email every single boot company
during coronavirus.
You've got time, email every one of them
and play with different titles.
Have you seen my videos on
YouTube opportunity for you.
That's one title.
Dear Boottown YouTube
social media collaboration
and opportunity read inside
like just play, play play play.
- And do you think that there is more
of an opportunity to get to them now
because I've done all that several times
in the past and I haven't heard anything.
- Yes, and maybe you wrote shitty
and maybe you wrote, right?
Tell me the truth, Jeremiah,
how many people have you emailed?
Tell the truth.
- I don't even know.
It's every single boot
company that there is
and then I also email
everybody who puts ads
on my Instagram or Facebook.
And I did that like at
least three times each.
- Let me tell you another story.
Remember when your
content wasn't doing well
and then you switched it up
and you did boots and it worked.
- Yes.
- Your copy on the email
title and the pitch is shit.
- Okay.
Good.
- You're gonna email every one of them
and try different tactics.
You were either to salary
not selling enough.
You didn't make it bigger
about a social media campaign.
Have you want to do something
that will super work.
Look at the boot company,
then go to their Instagram,
YouTube and Twitter
and then right was bored
during the Coronavirus,
I audited all your social media,
then you give them your
opinion on their YouTube,
Twitter and Instagram
and then nothing else,
nothing else.
They'll just see your signature
and then your URL to your YouTube channel.
Under think, "Who the fuck
is this and this is smart."
They're gonna reply to you
minimally saying thank you
because you spent 30 minutes of time
thinking how smart when I just told you
- Yeah.
That's great.
Perfect.
Thank you so much, Gary.
I appreciate it.
- Have a great day Jeremiah.
Thanks for watching.
- Peace.
- TRG coming in with more concepts,
guys, today's an action day.
Notice a lot of you tweeting about it.
Today's the fucking action day.
Big shout out to Brandon's even just said
I'm the coolest motherfucker in the world.
or live please hit me up on Twitter.
A lot of you have been engaged
with me way more on Twitter.
But today's action day.
I've given a lot of tactics
a lot of real life shit,
a lot of stuff you should be doing.
So please do after this.
We're gonna get off in half an hour
and I want you to fucking do it daily.
We just keep giving some shout
outs to people on Twitter.
Amazing posit Josh alley what's good JB?
JB, JBJ
This person actually did shave
his head on the side too.
Who didn't sit yeah
I did see said Brandon Z gave me that love
the sound of her wanting
to accept the follow them.
WineTex.com, sign up with my dad.
Patience is the key name.
That is true.
What's going on Dustin?
Give me some shitty transitions here.
Well, we're supposed to have like two
or three people in the fucking
- [Dustin] Yeah, I'm trying to connect.
I leave but I think this issues going.
- Yeah, I think when you
I think when you have that
problem you got to throw,
actually.
Hi.
Aileen.
You're still on mute.
- Morning.
- Good morning.
How are you?
Where are you from?
- I'm from Miami, Florida.
- Good.
- So I'm a photographer.
I've been doing this for
about a year professionally.
And I'm doing my own
portfolio, hiring models.
I am DMing people,
but the DMing is not really
going anywhere for me.
- Are you spamming them?
- Kind of Yeah, I even got muted
by one of my favorite people.
- You like I said, the last guy,
you have to bring people value.
- I try a lot.
I go with people that I know.
I'm kind of like you like I
emailed you a couple days ago,
telling you that I could
be your photographer
and I could do events
and product photography
and all of this and I'm doing that
but I'm not really--
- Are you offering it for free?
- Yes,
I do a lot of for
- Are you starting the sentence with like,
I love what you do.
I'd like to do a free photo
shoot with no strings attached.
Is that when you're writing?
- Yeah.
- Good.
So then I think let's convert it from DMs.
if you're not getting the cadence there,
let's start leaving comments.
- I started doing that too on Twitter,
mostly on Instagram,
- Let's do it on Instagram saying,
hey, Ronnie, we love your stuff.
Whenever you're in Miami,
I'd love to do some free
photography for you.
Because then some other people
may see it in the comments,
and maybe it's not Roddie Ricch,
but you might be able
to get somebody else.
- Okay, okay, I'll start doing that too.
So I'm kind of stuck
right now with photography
other than the DM thing.
I'm not really sure what to do next.
I have a posting on--
- You're posting on Pinterest?
- Pinterest, no, not Pinterest.
I'm posting on Instagram and LinkedIn.
LinkedIn I've been doing a lot lately
because I just got into
it through a lot me.
So I just started about
three or four days ago
and I just been like
spamming my whole LinkedIn.
- I think, first you
have to post everywhere.
And second, you have to have strategy
to what you're posting.
It's not just posting
for the sake of posting.
For example, if you post on LinkedIn
Hey guys bored with Corona
like everybody else,
doing a live stream to teach photographers
how to be better at photography.
If you're interested email me here,
that's gonna get seven people to apply.
- Live Stream, okay?
- You got to bring value, right?
And value can come in a free photo shoot,
but when you're super famous, I mean,
I get offered free
photography 4000 times a day.
- Okay.
- But you reaching out to my sister
and offering her free
photography might matter.
You know what I mean?
Like all these different games,
you bring value to people
by doing livestream
and teaching them how to do
photography is a flip on it,
which that may lead to that
person telling their dad
that you taught them and
then their dad has a business
that then asks you to do photography.
Like it's all about innovation ideas.
Pinterest is a real place
that I think you could find
some paper so you should
go learn that platform.
I think you should start a photography,
You start a Miami photography group,
Facebook group, immediately.
Very high on Facebook groups.
I think there's huge opportunity there.
And I like narrow.
I like the Miami photography grid.
Right.
- Okay,
- So those are some ideas.
- Okay, sounds good, Gary, thank you.
I just wanted to tell you one more thing,
please my boyfriend,
he lost his cousin about a year ago
and he was really, really down.
I couldn't even get him out of it.
But I showed him your trash talk,
'cause he used to do that as a hobby.
So I've been showing him
the trash talk videos.
And he's been doing very, very
well with his flipping stuff
and he has passion.
He's happy now
and I wanna thank you
for doing that for him.
- Thank you for saying that.
- Yeah, it's been very hard for us
because we're both doing
something on the side.
And we're both busy.
And before you I couldn't
get him out of that hole.
- Thank you for saying that.
- So thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much again.
- Thank you so much.
Have a good day.
- You too, bye bye.
- Thank you guys all for
sharing these news stories
means the world to me.
John does not drink wine.
Do you?
Need to backup to Katie?
Today is an extra day Mike long.
iPad Pro, aka Chris Bird in the building.
What's good.
- What's going on man?
- Life is good.
Where are you from?
- Indiana.
We're practically in the
woods in Kentucky right now
with this whole quarantine stuff going on.
- Respect.
Respect, respect, respect.
How can I help you, bro?
- Well, hey, first thing
I want to do a shout out
to all of our service workers.
I know they don't get enough
credit nurses, doctors,
grocery store clerks, all that stuff, man,
they're putting yourself
at risk and it's not a
So not really put them on a platform,
but they need to, with all
the shit that's going on.
- I agree, Chris, thank
you for saying that.
- Yeah, man.
Hey.
So I'm reaching out.
I own a small boutique,
real estate firm in Indiana.
And I live in a division one college town
and I'm always looking to be different.
I'm not into like competing with people
when it comes to doing the exact same shit
that they're doing.
So I love what I'm doing.
I don't need the motivation,
super excited about
where my team is going,
where my business is going.
But, I wanna be connected to the community
a little bit more to
the to the university.
And from what I've researched,
and I researched a lot,
nobody's doing what I wanna do,
which is, can you hear me okay?
- I can hear you great.
I was excited about jumping in.
You just said something
that excites me, which is
I really get worried
that people think that
they have to find something
that other people don't do.
I'm pumped that you're about
what you're about to tell me.
I think that's great, too,
because that's always a great thing to do.
But I wanna remind everybody
watching right now,
a lot of people don't do things
because somebody else is already doing it.
And I keep reminding people.
It's not about that.
It's about are you better at it?
Now, do you find something
nobody else is doing
and you're great at it.
It's a fucking monster.
So I'm really excited to hear
what you're about to say.
But that's why I did that concept of
like nobody else is doing it
has really been on my mind.
Because I'm like,
No, no, no, no, no, you're not.
Everything's already been done.
Stop worrying about that.
Just be fucking great at what you do.
But nonetheless, go ahead.
What do you want to do?
- No, no, you're right.
I do a little bit of the other stuff too.
But I'm sure for the
next for the next year.
- I get it.
So you're in a meeting?
I don't meet all the time.
- Yeah.
- Chris, I expect you to
sign up for WineText.com
- And I heard you say that earlier.
And I'm like, Gary's just gonna
pound me with text messages.
- So today, what do you like wine?
- I love it.
- Dude, it's only one a day like honestly,
we literally sold a 40 every store
in the country $48 Pinot noir
yesterday at 50 a bottle.
Free Shipping like it's the ugliest thing.
No, no, dude, it's every day's a steal.
It's groupon and it's
best year one for wine
and the friction is
insane you get the text
and you just reply for and
here's my biggest thing.
The fuck are you buying
wine from somebody?
Like some supermarket
that you don't give a fuck
you actually like me?
And it's a better price
in the sheet you're buying
it makes no fucking sense.
- I have some girls and
I'll get your take on this.
Have some some girlfriends
who are in this.
This clean crafted wine,
no headaches, all type of
all that type of stuff,
but what's your take on it on that?
- Wine has natural sulfates in it.
- Yep.
- Like I think it's a marketing ploy.
- I think it's horseshit.
- Of course it's working.
The brain is the most
underrated thing of all time.
If I tell you you're not
gonna get a headache,
you're not gonna get a headache.
- Right, right.
- I think it's garbage.
Wind with a good positioning
that tricks people.
And that doesn't bother me either.
But I think you, Chris, should
sign up for WineText.com
- I'm in just because you said it--
- All right, go ahead.
- All right, so university town,
the University of town that I'm in hired
over 100 faculty last year
and that's fairly high wage positions.
And then there's also the,
it's a very transit type of job as well.
So professors, faculty tenure
and clinical or transit near
always moving town so it's
this base that I would get.
Well, the hiring process is very
departmental or compartmentalized.
So let's just say the
business school hires
their own professors and
then they would recommend
a brokerage now you can't steer.
brokerage, you can't
steer the new employee
to a brokerage but you can recommend,
but I would love to be the brokerage
of the university and it's
a interesting conundrum.
Because the university is a state school.
And you can advertise, but it's,
25, $50,000 per year to do that,
and that being a small brokerage.
I don't have the funds for that yet.
- But you could also run pre roll ads
on YouTube, based on people searching
the University on Google
and completely crush it.
Let me explain.
If you're a professor that's coming in,
or if you're just somebody
considering the school,
a million different variables,
but let's just talk
about your point there.
When I heard you say, 100
people I'm like, okay,
and high net worth, and
they move around like,
this is good business for you.
Makes sense?
- Yeah.
- One of the things you
can do is Google AdWords,
and YouTube pre roll
based on the university
and intercept a lot of those
people and build awareness
that way, and not have the
school and the 25 to 50K
be the toll booth.
But have Google be the
toll booth for a fraction
of the price.
Let me give it a big pretend
Professor Vaynerchuk at,
Brown and now I'm
transferring to this place.
So I'm definitely gonna
google the university,
that's like money in the bank.
That night, I go to watch
a wine video on YouTube.
And the pre roll is literally
you and you're saying,
"Hey, are you going to
Indiana University?"
Are you considering to move to
or around Indiana University
and I'm like, What the fuck?
And then I'm gonna listen to you,
that shit is gonna
convert like fucking crazy
and you're gonna get
other people by accident,
who are just searching
the university or a parent
who's like, I wanna move
on this my kid I'm moving
by the university like,
there's a million other
people you're going to get
for a fraction of the
cost, Google arbitrage
all those kind of things.
You just have to be good
at knowing how to target
and you have to be good at
the video that converts them.
But that's what you should do, Chris.
- No, I like you're giving me direction.
And that's what I wanted
to get with you with.
Hey, before I leave, I
got to tell you this,
that I've been watching
you for a couple years,
which a lot of people have.
But, my wife was listening to you one day.
And she was like, "That guy
is so loud and annoying."
Like, she goes, why do you listen to him?
I'm like, "Cause he's always positive."
So I told her I was gonna come
on the show or possibly be on
the show today.
She goes with the loud guy.
I'm like, "Yeah, with
the fucking loud, guy."
She goes, "Jesus."
- I totally get it.
Like, it's really fascinating.
My communication style, obviously,
makes a lot of people love it.
And then there's definitely
a group that doesn't love it.
But to your point, what
I'm proud of and long term
what ends up happening is,
it's what's being said,
not how it's being said.
And most of all,
and this has been a
theme of this whole day.
I just know how to be me.
And do I know that if I
talked more in this tone
and tenor like I'm talking right?
Now versus how I get them.
Sometimes the way you do it, it's right.
It's right because it's me
right Chris just like for you,
the way is right is not to replicate me
but to do it your way.
And hopefully one day
I'll win over the wife.
- Well, it's undeniable is
your positive doesn't matter
if you're talking to a 12
year old, or an 18 year old,
you're always positive.
You never downplay anybody.
You appreciate their position,
and that's exactly what you're doing.
And I appreciate that as well.
I think everybody does.
That's why that's why you're so popular.
- So thank you.
Listen, here's my secret
plan with WineText.
Now I just realized why I
want you to be on it so bad.
You're gonna get such a
ridiculously delicious wine
for such a cheap price.
Your your wife's gonna drink and be like,
"Chris's, this is the
best wine I've ever had."
And you have like, "The loud guy."
- Gary V said so.
- Love it.
Talk to you soon, brother.
- All right, man.
- Take care.
- Hi, Susanna.
- Hi, Gary.
Oh my God, I'm such a huge fan.
I can't believe that I'm actually
talking to you right now.
This is like you.
I'm gonna have a little moment here.
Thank you so much for being
who you are and just inspiring
me so much every day.
I read your first book,
and I'm in the process
to do audiobooks.
So I'm doing the audiobook
version of it now
- Do you like when I read it?
- I love it because you give
these like extra little things
you always go off.
I'm like, you're like
I have to add this in
because this is new.
This has changed.
And it's just like, it's amazing.
I love it.
I feel like I wanna ask you
a million different questions
but I'm gonna try to stick to one.
And you kind of covered some of the things
that I've been feeling with
one of the previous calls,
but I'm gonna ask anyway.
So I feel like I have a
lot of different interests.
And I've always been this way I've always,
like not really had like
one thing that I felt like
I was like really good at or
that was like calling to me.
And I and I feel like now I'm
33 years old, I have two kids.
And yeah, and I just
feel like I'm not going,
like I'm still kind of like moving
from one place to the other
and trying different things.
And I want to be in a
place where I'm like,
Okay, this is what it is.
This is like make moves.
- Why do you want?
Are you tired?
Do you think you should?
Or do you enjoy being a renaissance woman?
Everybody makes this thing as a negative,
and I think it's a positive.
But I think society is more
structured and one school.
I was, my simple question is,
why do you want to fight?
Like, why is for you as a human
not an ideology or something
that was put in your head for you, you?
Why?
- Because I feel like I want to be great
at something.
- Why?
What about being just great about being?
I'm being serious about
what I'm about to say?
What about just being great.
And being Susanna?
- But what does that mean?
I can't wrap my head
around what that means.
In my mind, I wanna be a professional
or non professional expert at something.
- Why?
- I don't know.
I don't know.
- Well, this is a great conversation.
This is what's fun about this, right?
This is why I have the enormous blessing
of people following me
because I'm good at this
thing of like talking right?
I think it's really powerful question.
Why do you need to be an
expert in something, for whom?
And why and how did
that become an ideology?
And what does it mean?
I mean, do you want to be an expert
because that will put
you in a position to make
a lot more money without
that would be a reason
why that's there's
nothing wrong with that.
I'm just trying to get to why.
- I think that it yes, there
comes the more money aspect,
- But let's talk about that for a second.
I would argue that that
might be the whole reason,
and that's an order, like a
big chunk, and I will be okay.
What you'll appreciate
is, if that's the case,
we might be able to
actually get there through
a different path, which is
why I'm knocking on this door.
Maybe you, this could be subconscious.
You think being an expert or great
at something will then
lead to leverage to make it
financially sound that makes sense to me.
That's logical.
But I would argue with you that maybe
that's not the way you should do it.
First of all, you have to figure out
how to monetize something.
There's a lot of people
who are massive experts
at shit that don't make a fucking dollar
because they don't know
how to build a business.
See where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- So like, I'm fearful
that the expert thing
is the logical step in your mind.
But then when we become
an expert at fucking,
because we stumbled on you being the best
at making raspberry jam,
you still don't know
how to fucking sell raspberry jam.
- I'm still gonna have that
void, where I'm going to be
still thinking that I need
something more or that
- Maybe, or, again, you're putting this
in a negative box.
I'm super proud that I do a ton of shit.
- I know and I hear you
say that all the time.
And it made me feel so
good about doing that too
because I'm like, okay, so Gary does that
and he's obviously very
successful and in a lot
of different things and
you were saying how to you
it's okay to do 10 different things.
That's just who you are.
And then that's how it works for you.
- Yeah.
And I think first of all,
being a mother of two in itself
is like the fucking big game.
Right?
There's First of all, just
- It's very big.
It's very I have a two and a half year old
and a one year old.
Man, it's really crazy.
But I feel like I'm like
chasing my tail constantly.
- You should, you want something,
You want to do something
in addition to that's amazing.
- Yeah, yeah, because I know
they're gonna go to school
when they're a little older.
And I'm going to be like,
"Okay, so now what?"
Yeah.
What and I don't want to
I don't mean fingers.
- Who were you as a girl?
Like as a little girl?
What were you into?
- Ah, I was into like, I
don't even know like stickers
gymnastics
- New Kids on the Block.
- Oh, they can say guys,
- I don't kow.
- Oh, yeah, Backstreet Boys.
- Okay.
But this this will give
me a huge insight to you.
Which Insync or Backstreet Boys
or 98 Degrees kid did
you think was the cutest?
- Okay.
Backstreet was--
- Was that like he was sweet too
- And if you remember
- we had like a sweet vibe.
- Yeah, heaven like
- Kevin he felt like.
- Yeah, right.
Like a little creepy.
Yeah.
- Dad not like your neighbor
- Right
And I didn't like to go for my husband
and I didn't like the
main one that everyone
likes to kind of like the,
because Brian wasn't like the main one.
I don't think
- No, he was it wasn't
like big Nick, Nick Carter,
Nick now, Nick.
- Dreamy.
Yeah, whatever.
- Nonetheless, what we're going with
all of that is the thing
most likely is the thing
that you actually liked
the most from zero to 22
is most likely the place
where you'll find the most success
because it's predicated
on interest and passion,
which then means you'll persevere
through the tough times,
because you actually like
sewing, you actually like soccer.
You actually like 98 Degrees
and Nicholas Shea, like,
so I'm trying to go to the place
that is your interest
graph, because interests,
like tend to really play
out nicely in this scenario.
- Yeah, I absolutely agree with you.
And I think I've probably heard
it from you a million times.
And that's what I've
been trying to dig into.
So like, I went to
school, I'm a pathologist.
And I think that I pretty much did that
because that's what my parents were like,
you should do that.
That's like a safe thing,
even though right now.
It's not that safe.
This is pandemic and we're
fucking not able to actually go
see patients.
So it's just like, that's
what I did after I graduated.
Start working I worked in a
couple of different settings
and to just try to try to
see like, do I want to work
with adults?
Do I want to work with kids?
Do I like this population?
Do I like that population?
And in the meantime,
I got certified as a polities instructor.
My husband has a physical
therapy practice.
So I started working
with him to try to like
to he's a physical therapist.
So yeah, these physical
therapy go hand in hand.
I started doing some newborn photography.
I am all over the place.
- You are, you are making the same mistake
that most people make, like
I'm sitting you're smiling,
fired up.
And you think like, 98%
of the world thinks that
that means you're not
focused and that you like
and that you're all over
the all over all over
the place is the biggest strength
and everybody thinks it's bad
because everybody thinks like, the system
and you clearly hear if
you go back to your story,
like if your parents
are like saying like you
like have followed the game I get it.
You have demonized all over the place yet,
even though following the
game, you have gone out
and follow your soul and I've tried
tasting different things.
I'm proud of you.
I think that's great.
- Thank you.
I just,
I kind of don't want to
keep being a beginner
at everything all the time.
- You put school
and certification and expertise
on a pedestal and it is not.
- No, yeah, no, it's not.
- I would rather I'd much rather you do
11 more things between
now and 54 and a 54.
realized that you were a horse whisperer,
and nobody has a better
connection to horses
than you in the world.
And that you're getting
paid $50,000 to consult
against horses in bucking Kentucky,
because when you come and
pet them and whisper to them,
they run faster.
Maybe that's your destiny.
- Maybe, but what I kind of
wanted to say was that I was
since I was like, okay,
I'm a speech language
pathologist I went to school
for this let me try to
see if I can like find
something that
- Happiness or joy
- Yes happiness and joy.
And I'm already in it it's the thing
that I have the most experience
in technically at this point
- And?
- And, so I was like the one thing
that I haven't tried
yet was really working
for myself
- Good.
- And that's something
that I think I've always
wanted to do.
I remember when I was in
college, my dad's like,
what do you want to do?
I was like, I want to major in business
and he's like, what do you want to do with
that opened up a business?
Like he he was a who's just like what?
I'm also Russian became
from the former USSR.
I feel like you're like my
older, wiser big brother.
That's why like, feel this like,
I love listening to you so much.
And they have a mentality
that you can probably
understand but your
parents were entrepreneurs.
My parents were not so
it's a different mentality.
And so I think they were kind
of very, like, don't do that.
That's hard.
That's scary.
That's unknown.
Whatever was discouraging my whole life,
- Knowing the place you come from,
I know that 33 is like
an old bag from where
our parents came from.
But listen to me all the time,
- Right (laughs)
- It's like if you
weren't in like a 33 year,
like fit,
like if you're not a grandma by 42 and
so I, I have a lot of empathy for that.
Listen to me, your young as fuck,
you clearly have entrepreneurial DNA.
because of communism, a lot of your family
that is your parents, parents
and parents, parents, parents
might have been entrepreneurs,
but it's not known because
it was so suppressed
and so scary to do that.
You need to go scratch that itch.
While in parallel,
you need to start a Baking
Company and do pumpkin pies
like do not say no for yourself.
- And then like Instagram
and things like that,
like when trying to
develop a personal brand.
- Yes all those things.
- Like things that I post, it's
all it's okay to just like,
one day posted, apply these next day post
about eating therapy the
next day posted on the kids
and like, yes because just
because like it's confusing,
- It's not confusing.
It's Suzanna.
- It's me.
- All right.
And that's all those they got it.
- Yeah.
Right
- Talking about the New
York Jets and garage saleing
and sports cards, and that
potentially is confusing it
but it's not.
It's who I fucking am.
- Yeah, so it's all those things.
Okay, cool.
Thank you so much.
One last thing, if you can.
It's like a pretty general question.
Like just being in this moment in time
is with this pandemic.
Is there anything that you think is like?
I don't know just kind of
like a good like strategy
that you might be if
you can even talk about
it like you that you're doing
or that you can give advice
to anyone else out there.
- Gratitude.
- Yeah,
- Do you understand it, this
pandemic happened in 1991.
You and I wouldn't be
talking to each other.
- I know.
- We wouldn't have human connection.
No internet.
This is the greatest,
greatest time to like, reset,
be thoughtful, be grateful.
Gratitude,
gratitude will get everybody through this.
I don't care.
Then now somebody's watching, like,
how do I be grateful when I lost my job?
I'm like, by being grateful.
Like, life is twists and turns.
That because where our families
come from, there's people
I'm an optimist.
I think somebody's life got saved
because of Corona because
if they were actually
living their normal
life, today was the day
that we're going to get hit by a car.
- Yeah, but there's like
grant opportunities right now.
- Unlimited.
- Like and yeah,
- Make content, make content
make content I gotta run.
I gotta get to this conference call.
I see everybody thank you
so much for another episode
of Tea with Gary V, I will
be back tomorrow 9 a.m.
Tea with Gary, if you
enjoy this, please take
a screenshot right now
and your monthly setup.
I'd like you to take a screenshot of this
and share it on social with the link.
Sitting sitting giving you a chance here.
Please take a screenshot and
tweet it Facebook Instagram it.
Actually, we're gonna do this
team is what I want to do.
I'm gonna take this, if you're
watching screen shoot this
take a photo of it.
Post it on your Instagram
with hashtag Tea with Gary V.
post about the show your comments
how you've been seeing it,
how you enjoy it,
but put hashtag tea with Gary
V post on your Instagram.
My team is going to go into
the people that post right now
with that hashtag on
Instagram in a couple hours.
Look at everybody who
did it and dm several
of you to be the questions for tomorrow.
That's how we're gonna
do questions tomorrow.
For everybody takes a photo of
this right now and puts it in
Their Facebook Instagram
feed not stories in their
feed with the hashtag tea
with Gary V and a couple
of sentences on why they like
the show why they don't like
the show, whatever it is.
So here we go.
I'm going to set up
again two more seconds.
- [Dustin] We also mentioned the fact that
some international people
can't get on community
so this would be a good
opportunity for them.
- Can they hear that?
What you just said?
- [Dustin] No, I have to say.
- So Dustin just informed me
that this is the opportunity
for international people
to get on because we've
been taking the questions
from community my 212931573
ones so now Canada, Europe,
everybody stand up.
Here's your chance.
Putting on Instagram tea
with Gary V Tom lives Good to
See you.
Thanks, everybody.
Love you guys so much.
Thanks, team.
Thanks, Dustin.
See everybody.
See you tomorrow.
(upbeat music plays)